hoy se cumplen 20 años del corralito en
Argentina la grave crisis económica
política y social de 2001 por más de 3
años los argentinos venían soportando la
recepción más prolongada de la historia
de su país la pobreza había aumentado 12
puntos porcentuales durante ese periodo
y el desempleo era récord con 3 de cada
10 trabajadores desempleados el gobierno
del entonces presidente Fernando de la
Rúa que había asumido hacía ya 2 años
para ese entonces se enfrentaba un
dilema gracias a una ley aprobada una
década atrás que ha estado el valor de
la moneda argentina el dólar y también
la demanda por estos había superado
ampliamente la capacidad del país
sudamericano de general estás divisas
los argentinos entonces empezaban a
desconfiar de la solidez del sistema y
enviar sus dólares a cuentas en el
exterior
específicamente a la vecina Uruguay en
ese contexto de la rubentonces se firmó
el decreto bautizado como el corralito
para así evitar la caída del sistema
financiero pero desató todo lo contrario
una crisis social política e incluso
institucional a los argentinos se les
permitió sacar un máximo de 250 pesos o
dólares en efectivo a la semana de sus
cuentas una cifra que por supuesto no
cubría el ingreso mayoritario de la
población en ese momento también se
prohibieron las transferencias de dinero
al exterior veamos entonces el momento
en el que se decretó este corralito
hemos tenido que adoptar una medida
transitoria de limitación a la
extracción de dinero en efectivo
y solo se podrá ser durante este periodo
de 90 días por cifras de 250
pesos semanales ahí vemos el anuncio del
que fuera el ministro de Economía de De
la Rúa anunciando todo lo que fue este
corralito y lo que después desató algo
que vamos a analizar con Fernando
Marengo economista jefe de Arriazu Makro
analista gracias entonces por estar con
nosotros Fernando en directo América de
France 24 muy buen día le pregunto
porque el gobierno del entonces
presidente la Rúa tomo estas medidas y
no fueron acertadas no sé qué le parece
a usted
qué tal Raúl Buendía haber
definitivamente en el momento que se
tomaron las medidas ya no había más
alternativa que restringir la
circulación de los pesos yo diría que
Argentina tiene una historia permanente
desequilibrio fiscal que se financia o
emitiendo deuda o peso y siempre termina
el país en una crisis y hacía de deuda o
en una crisis inflacionaria en ese
momento el problema era la deuda estaba
básicamente los bancos
ahora porque 20 años después Argentina
continúa en esta crisis que ha cambiado
en el país luego de 20 años es de
corralito
bueno a ver claramente no cambio mucho
por eso estamos de nuevo en una
situación que se puede definir como
apremiante Argentina tiene una historia
de décadas de déficit fiscal donde el
gobierno siempre gasta más de lo que
recauda y esto genera necesidades de
financiamiento que si se lo financia
metiendo deudas terminamos en la crisis
de deuda argentina tiene un triste
récord de reestructuraciones de deuda y
si se lo financia metiendo pesos
terminamos con un problema inflacionario
y Argentina también tiene un triste
récord de historia inflacionaria nivel
mundial ahora y vamos que no es la
primera vez que se ha hecho un corralito
a nivel mundial también lo vimos en
Grecia en el año 2015 que es y cómo
funciona un corralito
básicamente lo que ocurre es que en el
momento de desconfianza la gente va a
retirar sus ahorros de una entidad
financiera y claramente esos ahorros no
están en la entidad financiera sino que
el banco se los presto a alguien
generalmente los saludables sería que se
lo preste al sector privado para
inversiones en el caso del 2000
Argentina que casi la mitad ese crédito
había ido a la compra de deuda del
gobierno entonces llega un momento donde
los ahorristas sienten desconfianza
quieren retirar sus recursos de los
bancos el banco no tiene la liquidez
porque se la ha prestado el tesoro
entonces la única forma de evitar el
quiebre por un problema de liquidez de
las entidades es hacer un corral y es el
corralito todos los pesos quedan dentro
del sistema financiero no se lo puede
sacar para comprar divisas y la única
operación permitida es transferir los
pies entre distintas cuentas bancarias
Fernando la relación habríamos ahora de
la actualidad la relación de Argentina
con el Fondo Monetario Internacional que
como lo vemos ya ha sido ella amores y
odios y alejarse entonces el país de
este organismo o todo lo contrario que
tiene que será más Argentina para poder
superar está crisis financiera que sufre
actualmente
a ver
y evitar un default también con el Fondo
Monetario lo cual impediría los
desembolso además del Banco Mundial qué
son los únicos fuerte de divisa que
enfrenta actualmente la economía más
allá de las exportaciones digamos que
eso es lo que tendría que hacer entonces
el gobierno argentino para sortear esta
crisis económica pero en la práctica si
lo puede lograr el gobierno del actual
presidente Alberto Fernández
saber es el desafío que tiene la
pregunta la pregunta si puede o no creo
que ahí hay tres claves primero hay que
entender la necesidad lo segundo hay que
estar dispuesto a hacerlo y lo tercero
hay que tener el poder político para
enfrentar las consecuencias la reducción
del déficit fiscal el ajuste del tiempo
de cambio ajuste de tarifas congelada
descongelar el precio de los productos
que hace un par de meses que no se
permiten aumentar en un país que tiene
más de 50 % de inflación anual
claramente empieza general desequilibrio
ahora ajustar el desequilibrio determina
sectores ganadores y perdedores y hay
que tener el poder político para
enfrentar aquellos sectores que son
perdedores si se aflojan te la demanda
de los sectores que son perdedores el
riesgo es que la inflación se acelere
incluso por arriba del 50% anual la
actual de la infección que es uno de los
principales problemas no solo de
Argentina sino también de nuestra región
de América Latina como se puede cómo se
puede parar esta infracción que todos
los días va creciendo
es cierto que toda América Latina y yo
diría que también una parte importante
del mundo empezado del problema
inflacionario
ahora Argentina un caso extremo los
últimos 70 años promedio 65 % de
inflación
por año y en los últimos 3 años
en el mundo
todos los estados tienen que entender a
revertir los déficit fiscales los cuales
incurrieron durante la pandemia en aquel
momento fue necesario ahora ya no es más
necesario obviamente habrá que ver cómo
avanza en la variante la Omicron pero yo
no creo que volvamos a un escenario como
el del año pasado a nivel mundial y lo
segundo es que pasa con el precio
internacional de materias primas y esto
básicamente te ha explicado por el
riesgo inflacionario en Estados Unidos y
que puede hacer la reserva federal
contacta interés para tratar de contener
en la medida que la Reserva Federal
exitosa controlando la inflación en
Estados Unidos ese choque externo
debería ayudar también americana